la fin de cinq mois d'incertitude pour
le site vallourec de cosne-sur-loire
l'annoncé tombée ce matin l' usine
restera ouverte et l'intégralité du
personnel sera conservé un poids en
moins pour les 120 salariés
ten espérait on s'attendait pas à une
reprise aussi positive avec 100% de
reprise du personnel donc rien à dire
maintenant faut espérer que ça va ça va
fonctionner va repartir sur des bonnes
bases
c'est une excellente nouvelle pour les
reprennent l'ensemble du personnel et à
pas mal de choses encore qui vont être
faits à pas mal de choses qu'on pas été
encore signé mais apparemment c'est
encourageant le repreneur c'est le
groupe alti fort présent dans
l'industrie mécanique et les fluides
une réputation qui nourrit les espoirs
de pérennisation et de développement en
dehors des produits de forage tiendront
cas l'air d'être quand même assez solide
ils nous proposent des garanties qui
sont intéressants les jours à venir le
dire mais c'est bon c'est déjà quelque
chose de très bien
he a conservé une petite partie pétrole
et puis j'ai d'autres choses car on ne
sait pas encore ce qu'on va faire
d'autre bon c'est qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
des entreprises la direction du site de
caunes n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
ce dossier a suscité pendant cinq mois
l'attention des pouvoirs publics en
raison des aides perçues par vallourec
ces dernières années tout le monde s'est
battu et je crois que les élus ont joué
leur rôle
le gouvernement était très attentif à ce
dossier comme vous savez c'était monté
au plus haut sommet de l'état donc
on l'a bien vu quand on s'est déplacé à
paris au ministère que il y avait un
lien directement utilisés donc on était
un peu plus serein une bonne nouvelle
pour le bassin de caunes déjà éprouvée
ces dernières années en revanche les
interrogations demeurent à la charité
sur loire 17 emplois qui dépendent d'une
autre branche du groupe vallourec
ils sont toujours menacés